[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم
مشاهدينا الى مقابله خاصه نستضيف فيها
رئيس الحكومه الباكستانيه السابق عمران
خان سيد عمران اهلا بك معنا وشكرا على
الانضمام الينا في الواقع نحاورك في ظل
تطورات سياسيه يعيش داخل الباكستاني
متعلقه بحضرتك حضرتك متهم في ملفات فساد
وهناك كذلك دعوه لتحقيق معك ماذا في هذه
الازمه الى اين تتجه
هناك نحو 100 قضيه مرفوعه ضدي وهذه
القضايا تشمل مزاعم التحريض والتجديف
والارهاب وحتى قضايا قتل حيث اتهموني بقتل
شخص كل هذه القضايا وراءها دوافع سياسيه
لابعاد عن سباق الانتخابات فالمشكله هي ان
المعارضه تعرف تماما انها لا تستطيع الفوز
بالانتخابات ومن بين الانتخابات الفرعيه
التي يبلغ عدد مقاعدها 37 فزنا بثلاثين
منها فهم قلقون لان مشاركتنا في انتخابات
الثلاثين من ابريل ستتسبب في هزيمتهم
ولانهم يخشون الهزيمه فهم يحاولون ابعاد
عن السباق من خلال توجيه كل هذه القضايا
ضدي
ولكن المحكمه الباكستانيه تقول بانك تتهرب
من موضوع التحقيق
ماذا وراء هذا التصريح وهل حضرتك ستذهب
للتحقيق ستستجيب لهذه الدعوه
ما الذي تقصده بحياه مهدده هل هناك
تهديدات هل هناك مؤشرات على شيء
الاشخاص الذين حاولوا اغتيال يتولون الان
مناصب في السلطه ثلاثه منهم سيكررون
المحاوله مجددا لانهم يخشون اذا فزت في
الانتخابات فساخدعهم للمساءله ولهذا السبب
سيحاولون اغتيال مجددا والحكومه نفسها
اعلنت الناحيه مهدده ولكن بسبب جهات
خارجيه وانا اعرف ان الحقيقه هي انه ليست
هناك جهات خارجيه انما الحكومه نفسها هي
التي تحاول اغتيالي بالعوده للقضايا
وبالعوده لدعوه التحقيق مع حضرتك اخر قضيه
قبل قضيه الارهاب كانت القضيه المتعلقه
بما يعرف بصندوق الهدايا تقول بان هناك
جهات وراء تلفيق مثل هكذا قضيه كيف فسر
دعيني اوضح لك مساله الطوش خانه اي صندوق
الهدايا منذ 70 عاما في باكستان اذا تلقى
رئيس الدوله او الوزراء او كبار وضباط
الجيش هدايا فيجب ان توضع في صندوق
الهدايا وهي المكان الذي يقدرون فيه قيمه
الهديه وعلى مدى 70 عاما اذا حصل المسؤول
على هديه بامكانه شرائها بدفع نسبه من
قيمتها والنسبه تغيرت من 20% في السابق
لتصبح 50% في ايامي واذا لم يرغب المسؤول
بشرائها تعرض الهديه للبيع في مزاد علني
وهذا هو نفس القانون الذي اتبعته ولم اقم
باي عمل غير قانوني في هذه القضيه وعندما
تصل هذه القضيه الى المحكمه سيجدون ان
الشخص الوحيد الذي التزم بالاجراءات
القانونيه الخاصه بصندوق الهدايا هو انا
ما سبق ان اكتشفوه هو ان رئيسي الوزراء
السابقين اسف زرداري ونواس شريف اخذ
سيارات من صندوق الهدايا وهذه القضيه
مرفوعه ضدي لانني امثل لهم تهديدا في
الانتخابات وانا اعرف انني عندما امثل
امام المحكمه في هذه القضيه فستتم تبرئتي
وماذا بخصوص قضيه الارهاب الشرطه
الباكستانيه تتهمك وانصارك كذلك بالارهاب
هل لديك مخاوف من هذه القضيه
سببها التظاهر السلمي خارج مفوضيه
الانتخابات وهذا ما يحدث في الديمقراطيات
كلها اتهموني بالارهاب بينما كنت جالسا في
منزلي وعندما حذرت المحاكم بسبب القضايا
التي حضرها عدد كبير من انصاري تهموني
بقضايا ارهاب اخرى والجميع يعرف تماما
انني خلال خمسين عاما لم اخرق القانون
ابدا انا الشخص الوحيد الذي يثق به الشعب
وبامواله لقد جمعت اكبر كميه من الاموال
في باكستان وادير اكبر المؤسسات الخيريه
في البلاد
ومستشفيين وجامعتين وكلها للفقراء لان
الشعب يثق بي ولا احد يصدق المزاعم
الوارده في القضايا المرفوعه ضده
في الواقع الشرطه باكستانيه اتهمتك
بالارهاب على خلفيه دعوتك لانصارك بالخروج
وللتظاهر هل هذه الدعوه قد تؤجج وقد تصاعد
اكثر فيما يخص هذه التطورات تعتقد
التظاهر السلمي حق اساس في الديمقراطيه
كلها الالاف يتظاهرون في فرنسا بسبب
التقاعد هذا حقهم وفي انجلترا النقابات
تتظاهر مطالبه بحقوقها وزياده المرتبات
بسبب التضخم هذا هو حق كل مواطن حر في بلد
ديمقراطي طوال عمل سياسي لم اطالب حزب
ابدا بالقيام باعمال عنف التظاهرات كانت
دائما بحسب الدستور وكانت سلميه
صحيح ولكنهم اشتبكوا مع قوى الشرطه في
محيط منزل حضرتك عندما كانت شرطه تود
اعتقالك للتحقيق
هل هذه الخطوه يمكن ان تصعد من الموضوع
الشرطه لن يكن لديها الحق في اعتقاله
لانني دفعت كفاله لغايه الثامن عشر من
الشهر الحالي ومع ذلك جاءوا الاعتقال قبل
اربعه ايام من ذلك الموعد في الرابع عشر
من الشهر الحالي فالقانون على ان الشخص
الذي يقدم ضمانه متعهدا للوصول امام
المحكمه كما فعلت فلا يحق للشرطه توقيفه
ان انصاري تجمعوا امام منزلي من اجل
حمايته لانهم كانوا يدركون ان تصرف الشرطه
هو غير قانوني وان الشرطه اتت لخطفك وليس
الاعتقالي في كل الاحوال هل ستستجيب لي
دعوه التحقيق مع حضرتك اذا ما تم تامين
المحكمه كما طلبت
كوركسز سبق ان حضرته كل جلسات المحاكمات
كانت هناك قضايا قبل اصابه بالرصاص وبعدها
ايضا في المحكمه العليا في لاهور وفي
اسلام اباد في المره الثانيه لم اتخلف
ابدا عن الى المحكمه ما عدا مره واحده
عندما كان هناك تهديد جدي بعمليه ارهابيه
وفي المره الاخيره عندما ذهبت الى المحكمه
كانوا قد غيروا المكان الى موقع اخر امن
لقد اكدت مرارا انني ساحضر حالما تكون
حياتي امنه ليس لدي اي مانع من حضور
الجلسات في المحاكم مشكله ان الحكومه لا
تطبق القانون واختطفت انصاري واثنين من
كبار المسؤولين العاملين معي عضو مجلس
شيوخ ورئيس هيئه اركان اختطفوهما وعذبوهما
وقاموا بتعريتهما قبل ان يقدموهما الى
المحاكمه وهذا العمل غير شرعي وغير مقبول
في اي قانون فسبب هذا التجمع الكبير كلما
جاءت الشرطه لاعتقالي هو انهم يعرفون ان
الشرطه اما ستقوم بتعذيبه او ستضعني في
السجن في عدد من القضايا وكما ذكرت هناك
نحو 100 قضيه مرفوعه ضدي والسب ب الوحيد
هو منعي من المشاركه في انتخابات الثلاثين
من ابريل فقط
تحدث عن اصابتك في رجلك كيف تمت هذه
الاصابه سلامتك
كنت اعرف انه ستكون هناك محاوله لاختيالي
وظهرت في وسائل الاعلام واوضحت للجميع ان
وكاله استخباراتنا ورئيس الوزراء ووزير
الداخليه هم وراء العمليه كنت محظوظا جدا
لانهم لم يتمكنوا من قتله لان فتى شجاعا
كان يقف بين الجموع شاهد الرجل يخرج
المسدس فوضع يده في وجهه وانزله ولذلك
اصابت الرصاصات ساقي بدلا من الناحيه
العليا من جسدي انا محظوظ جدا لانني بقيت
على قيد الحياه وكان هناك مسلحان اخران
وعندما سقطت على الارض انطلقت الرصاصات
فوق راسي والا لكنت اصبت من اسلحتي هؤلاء
ايضا
جديده هي اصابه متعلقه
بمحاوله اغتيالك هل هناك محاولات
تتخوف منها خاصه وانك تتهم جهات في الداخل
ولكن كذلك من خلال تصريحاتك تتهم جهات في
الخارج
نورك
انا لا اتهم اطرافا خارجيه الحكومه هي
التي تقول ان هناك جهات خارجيه تحاول
اغتيال ولكنني ادرك ان الحكومه نفسها هي
التي تحاول قتلك لان الاشخاص الذين حاولوا
قتلى قامت الحكومه بتغطيه ما حدث فمفوضيه
التحقيق المشتركه توصلت الى حقائق اثبتت
انه كان هناك اكثر من مسلح واحد والحكومه
اشارت الى ان ثلاثه مسلحين حاولوا قتله
هناك شهود يثبتون وجود ثلاثه مسلحين ولذلك
فان التغطيه على محاوله اغتيال تمت من قبل
الحكومه وهؤلاء سيحاولون
مجددا
هذا فيما يخص محاوله الاغتيال ولكن فما
يخص سحب ثقه من حضرتك فيما يخص
سحبك او ازالتك من الحياه السياسيه من
منصبك كذلك صرحت واتهمت جهه خارجيه هل لك
دلائل على ذلك
يعني السلطه ماذا علي ان اثبت هناك مئه
قضيه مرفوعه ضدي والسبب وراء كل هذه
القضايا هو الزج بي في السجن كلها قضايا
زائفه واؤكد لك مره اخرى انا شخصيه عامه
منذ 50 عاما وهذه البلاد تعرفني والجميع
يعرف ان هذه القضايا زائفه والا لماذا جاء
هذا العدد الكبير من المناصرين لدعم عندما
سمعوا ان الشرطه تحاول اعتقاله وكل هذه
القضايا وراءها دوافع سياسيه لمجرمين
يحكمون في باكستان وكلهم مندعى عليهم
بقضايا فساد وسبب رغبتهم في ازاحه هو انهم
يدركون انه اذا فاز حزبي في الانتخابات
وهم متاكدون من فوزه اذا شارك وبحسب
استطلاعات عده فانه سيكتسح الانتخابات
لماذا المخاوف تتعلق بك انت تتحدث عن
امكانيه فوزك في الانتخابات القادمه ولكن
هناك الاكيد احزاب اخرى هناك مرشحين اخرين
لماذا تتكتل كل الجهات الداخليه لمحاوله
الايقاع بك بحسب ما تقول حضرتك ما الذي
يخيفهم
هناك اثناء عشره حزبا من جهه وحزبي لوحده
على الجهه الاخرى وفي الاشهر الثمانيه
الفائته ومن بين الانتخابات الفرعيه حصد
حزبه 30 مقعدا من بين 37
وحققنا نسبه فوز تقارب الخمسه والثمانين
في المئه وهذا ما يخشونه جميعا
نتوقف مع هذا الفاصل نستكمل من بعده هذه
المقابله ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد الى هذه المقابله
الخاصه في جزءها ثاني نستقبل ونحاور فيها
رئيس الحكومه الباكستانيه السابق عمرا خان
هل تعتقد بان هذه الازمه ستنتهي باعتقالك
وبسجنك او ستنتهي بتبرئتك ما هي حدودها
الى اين تتجه
السبيل الوحيد للخروج من هذه الازمه يكون
عبر انتخابات حره وعادله حزب ينتخبه الشعب
ويتخذ القرارات الصعبه لاعاده هيكله
باكستان من الانهيار الكامل السبيل الوحيد
للخروج هو من خلال انتخابات حره وعادله
ولا يوجد حل اخر مهما فعلنا سيستمر انعدام
الاستقرار السياسي وهذا يعني استمرار
الاقتصاد في الغرق
قبل هذه الانتخابات ما الذي تحضر لذلك
هذا ما يحاولون القيام به هم يفبركون
قضايا الاعتقال لنرى ما سيحدث لدي امل
بالمحكمه العليا وبالقضاء ولكنني مستعد
ايضا في حالته الاعتقال يوما ما وهم كادوا
يعتقلونني يوم السبت الفائت كما سبق وقلت
الى اي مدى تعول على الشارع بان يتحرك
الشارع لصالحك
هل هناك مخاوف من ان تحدث اشتباكات بين
انصارك وبين قوى الشرطه
المواجهات سبق ان حدثت فقد جاءت الشرطه
لمهاجمه منزلي من ثلاث جهات الاف عناصر
الشرطه شاركوا في العمليه ولم يحدث اي شيء
من هذا القبيل في تاريخ بلادنا لماذا
جاؤوا الى منزلي لانهم ارادوا تقديمي الى
محكمه اسلام اباد في الثامن عشر من الشهر
الحالي جاءوا في الرابع عشر من مارس
لاعتقالي من اجل المثول المحكمه بحسب
مزاعمهم مع انني كنت سامثل في الموعد
المحدد والقانون ينص على ان الشخص الذي
يقدم سند ضمان يؤكد حضوره الى المحكمه في
الموعد المحدد فلا يحك للشرطه اعتقاله ومع
ذلك جاءوا الاعتقاد والسبب كما قلت هو من
اجل ابعاده عن سباق الترشح للانتخابات من
خلال الزجب في السجن هذه الازمه السياسيه
تاتي مع محاولات باكستان محاولاتها
المستمره مع صندوق النقد الدولي هذه
الازمه الى اي مدى يمكن ان تؤثر على هذا
المسار الاقتصادي وعلى حاله الشعب
الباكستاني عموما
هذه الازمه بدات عندما ازيحت حكومتي
بمؤامره واستلم السلطه اشخاص يفتقدون الى
الصدقيه 60% من مجلس الوزراء كان خارجا
لكفاله بقضايا فسد عندما فرضت حكومتهم
علينا في ذلك الوقت بدات الازمه وقد
ازدادت سوءا يوما بعد اخر لانهم اساءوا
اداره الاقتصاد واتخذوا خيارات خاطئه ولم
يكونوا مستعدين بالمقارنه مع وضع الاقتصاد
في شهر مارس من العام الفائت عندما كنت
رئيسا للوزراء نجد ان صندوق النقد الدولي
امتدح اقتصاد باكستان وقال اننا نسير في
اتجاه نمو مستدام ومنذ رحيل حكومتنا في
شهر ابريل والاقتصاد يتراجع هؤلاء الاشخاص
الذين حكموا بلادنا منذ 30 عاما هم سبب
تراجع اقتصادنا لاننا عندما شكلنا الحكومه
في العام 2018 كنا نعيش اسوا ازمه
اقتصاديه واكبر عجز في الحساب الجاري وعلى
الرغم من جائحه كورونا قم بتحسين اقتصادنا
بعد تلك الفتره وقدمنا افضل اداء منذ 17
عاما ولكن منذ ان حدثت هذه المؤامره
وازاحت حكومتنا والاقتصاد يتراجع كنت لاعب
مشهور ومحبوب واخترت ان تدخل عالم السياسه
كنت رئيس وزراء تم اعتقادك فيما بعد
محاوله اغتيال لفت منها قضايا جنائيه
قضايا بالارهاب هل ندمت على دخول معترك
الحياه السياسيه
المعترك السياسي بالنسبه لي ليس مهنه انما
هو مهمه فقد دخلت هذا المعترك من اجل
بلادي الحركه من اجل العداله وحكم القانون
والديمقراطيه الحقيقيه والحريه هذه هي
القيم التي دخلت المعتركه السياسي من
اجلها قبل سته وعشرين عاما وما زلت اسير
على هذا النهج ومازلت اكرس حياتي له لان
الخالق وهبني الكثير فمسؤوليه تفرض علي ان
ابذل كل ما في وسعي من اجل بلادي اما
النجاح والفشل فهما بيد الخالق انا سابذل
ما في وسعي ولذلك اواجه المشكلات في كل
حين وقبل بضعه ايام هاجم منزلي وحطم
ابوابه ودخلوا اليه عنوه وانا لم اكن في
المنزل فقد كنت في اسلام اباد من اجل حضور
جلس محاكمه يوم السبت وزوجتي كانت بمفردها
في المنزل لم يحدث شيء من هذا القبيل في
بلادنا من قبل لم يحترموا حرمه بيتي مع
علمهم ان زوجتي كانت بمفردها في المنزل
وطوقت الشرطه منزلي ونهبته وهذا لم نشهد
له مثيلا من قبل هذا ما نتعامل معه عقليه
فاشيه ومجموعه مجرمين ولهذا السبب انا لا
اسمي عملي سياسيا بل اسميه جهادا فانا
احارب من اجل العداله في بلاده وساقاتل
طالما انا على قيد الحياه
شكرا لك سيد عمران اذا مشاهدينا كانت هذه
مقابله خاصه مع عمران خان رئيس الحكومه
الباكستانيه السابق نلقاكم في لقاءات
قادمه السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]